so kevin you you got an interesting
dynamic yourself you
uh in 2008 or 2009 i think you were at
the uh rnc convention or something like
that well
yeah but then you also golf with bill
clinton so it's like yeah
yeah
i don't know like i said i i that during
that time i uh i uh was friends with
david zucker i don't know if you know
who david zucker is he uh did airplane
and is he from wisconsin yes i know so
many people from wisconsin that talk
about david zucker and david is a huge
packer fan i'm a huge pack fan
and uh so david and i became friends and
and um
he wanted to do a movie about michael
moore which is like this is the movie i
did called american carol which
i played michael moore and uh it was a
spoof about how michael moore wanted to
take away fourth of july and so
i mean it was
i've always wanted to work with david
zucker because i love airplane and i
love uh of naked gun series and all
those kind of things so i was just yeah
i would say yes i said yeah i'll work
with you for sure but it was a pretty
much of a
you know it had a good cast it had uh
dennis hopper
kelsey grammer
um you know
david alexander david greer and um
uh leslie nielsen
um john
john that's right maybe that's some of
your political inclinations john you're
hanging around with john voigt long
enough next thing you know yeah you end
up at the rnc convention that's why
exactly i think he wanted us all go to
go there so
you know i'm not going to say no to john
boyd yeah so he's like yeah we're all
going to the rnc convention i'm like
well i'm going to be kind of labeled as
a republican he goes you're going to are
and yeah oh okay okay so i went and just
it just held i'd never been to a
convention before and so it was trip to
sea it was it was kind of wild to see
that uh political environment i'd never
been to a convention i would have i
would uh encourage anyone to go to a
political convention it's it's really
kind of wild have you ever spoken on the
floor of congress or anything like that
no my brother chris did yeah
yeah yeah yeah we got to show that i
don't know if we could show it was not
playing new game oh he was playing new
gingrich yeah he played newt gingrich
yeah it's on c-span we can watch it
mm-hmm yeah c-span is fine
yeah i know i think so set up the story
if you would kevin so he gets invited he
did it on snl and i think he got invited
to do that i think for it might have
been something to do with his birthday
or i don't know newt's birthday or
something i don't know i'm not sure
maybe not by the way newt's sitting
right there right no he liked it
different era man
sense of humor back then right yeah
exactly we're a little more it would
never happen right now it wouldn't
people would walk out they were offended
they would yeah
i mean this couldn't happen right now no
it couldn't we're too political
yeah
we can watch it later it's an
eight-minute clip but we're too
political now back then you could you
know go have dinner with uh you know and
did chris care about politics it was not
a lot not even the least my dad was a
republican so i think that's you know
but that's all he put thought into got
it he didn't really think too much about
it
i think he was more passionate about his
comedy than he was about politics or
anything well that's good i can see that
because anything that would because
chris was so much about pleasing the
audience that's the feeling at least i
get i may be wrong that he looked like
he was a guy that
was going to give his best and his
performance was going to be solid i
can't see him getting too political do
you think snl these days has gotten too
political i mean everything they're
doing with they did with trump and now
they get the guy who does trump he also
does buy it in but
clearly snl has sprinted left wow
they're making fun of janine pirro
marsha blackburn on the regular i think
lauren michael that show's been on the
air for i don't know how long i think
it's almost 50 years okay so just almost
just the fact that it's been on that
long is it is literally a wonder of the
world correct so to survive in in the
political i mean into in on television
for that long you have to do and lauren
knows this instinctively lauren michaels
he knows we have to survive
so he's like what works you know it's
throwing stuff against the wall politics
works for us
so the ratings are going up it's
capitalism and the ratings are going up
and so he's going to stick with what's
going you know they've always got
chambers right if you've got a pitch
that's working and if your curveball is
working you're going to keep i think i
think your brother played tip o'neill i
want to say at one point yeah he played
a lot of them he also played a guy named
howell heflin or something some senator
heflin back in the day at a giant chin
and he was like he was on the the
clarence thomas uh
and he was it was a hysterical what are
your thoughts on lorne michael's in
general if you have time to spend with
him at all i've talked to lauren yeah a
lot of different times he's the king i
mean he rules it over there so
uh you know he's i kind of like
intimidating he's an intimidating guy so
i i just say hello sir nice to see you
yeah i enjoyed the quote about what he
said about your brother though
uh he says because he's got this very
distinct like uh
not i don't know it's just very
straightforward voice he's like he's in
a category of people
[Music]
yeah he does that he's worked that are
infuriatingly talented
right basically saying that you just
have to recognize and um
and dive straight into it right i mean
it got to the point where they would put
it if you had a sketch on snl and it was
kind of you know reaching the point
where you're like i don't know what
we're going to do with this what this is
kind of a dud
he would find a way to make that sketch
good right so fall down or something
that's all it takes your brother you're
saying he had an instinct where he'd be
like i know how to make this funny you
know so
yeah so that's where lauren was like you
know we had a thousand sketches and
chris had come up with the solution to
like all of them you know he was a
genius that way but but uh
just find out what's going to be funny
do you have some favorite sketches that
come to mind that chris did oh geez i
think uh
i always liked i put some in the uh in
the documentary that one whether he's a
talent scout or something like that that
to me it was just hilarious like no no
no he's just big on everything this is
hilarious i think that was one of my
favorite he was like a talent uh agent
and it was really flamboyant the most
famous one is the chippendales one well
yeah him and patrick swayze yeah that
was one of the lunch lady
which one is that the lunch lady without
a lunch lady with adam yeah that was a
big yeah
wasn't it the gap store him in spade
where they were holding up the clothes
lay off me i'm starving yeah no he had
like five of the top i think they made a
list of them he had like two or three in
the top 20 you know sketches he really
did well on that how did pat started it
off with this but how did he come up
with the matt foley motivational speaker
live in a van down by the river that was
a bit actually written by bob odenkirk
in fact bob just wrote a book about it
wow and he said that back in second city
when we were in chicago that's where we
all trained
and there was a stage thing that bob
wrote and he was writing it i think for
himself but he didn't want to do it so
he gave it to chris to play the
motivational speaker so wow they did
that first in chicago at second city
yeah and then they brought it up to
saturday night live yeah if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]